all right end of the first day you still
got your heads
together i mean you started with
hanselman that's a lot
for first thing in the morning
and uh that so you get me at the end of
the day and you're gonna get me again at
the end on friday although they just
added another talk there was a they lost
a talk and said could you do an extra
one tomorrow and i'm like
sure which one you want she goes what do
you got ready
it's like well i did a space flight in
the 2020s talk would you like that i'm
like yeah yeah we'd like that i'm like
okay i'm doing space flight in the 2020s
tomorrow
which is not a lot of software but it's
fun
we'll talk about paid key price of kilos
to orbit
uh my name is richard campbell uh i am
uh from british columbia
so i am quite jet-lagged at the moment
i think i have to take this out and then
this wakes up right wake up
not waking up
this is my home my home's on the left
my neighbor's home is on the right
and we call this the animal highway
uh it's a wednesday morning about 6 a.m
and wednesday in my neighborhood is
garbage day
so this guy's just checking to see if i
put out my garbage early that's all
i didn't because you get a fine if you
put your garbage out early and you also
get it distributed all over your yard
though uh and you'll notice he actually
stops here his butt will stay in frame
he's just surveying his domain
that uh
yeah so that's
it's bear country where i'm from and we
we just live with them you get used to
it believe it or not
i have a the same clip of a mountain
lion coming down and that's not funny
mountain lions are very serious
bears are vaguely goofy really black
bears are pretty cautious
this that is a garbage collector more of
a garbage distributor actually
although there's one big male who's
learned to just grab a bag and head into
the into the ravine with it in the
forest with it so it's kind of like the
bear took your garbage out for you which
is that's why he's lasted as long as he
has
uh so you run across me before i wrote
my first line of code 1977
which is not the most important thing
that happened in 1977 the most important
thing to happen in 1977 was star wars
so i have my priorities straight i know
what's important and what isn't uh and
that was written on a trs-80 model one
which was a microcomputer made by
radioshack with 4k of ram
and except tape player to sew the
programs on and a 127 by 47 graphical
resolution i think we're playing star
trek
on the screen at the time and this had a
version of basic in it that wasn't a
microsoft basic it was actually a tiny
basic and it only had three error
messages
what
how
and sorry
i want to divide one by zero sorry
object is not found which really means
sorry i mean the difference when it's
windows is that it also makes you agree
with you
right
registry is corrupt okay
there's not a not okay button you have
to agree your registry is corrupt or you
cannot continue
uh i make a bunch of podcasts this is
the current list so my friend carl
franklin started.net rocks back in 2002
so 20-year anniversary coming up this
summer
um we will publish episode 1791
tomorrow
and i've been making run as since 2007
so that's a show for it pros and that's
been every wednesday since april of 2007
so we're at 800 and something
we did the tablet show briefly for about
three years back when we weren't sure
if.net rocked and we wanted an
alternative
it was scary time and we're going to
talk about that time racing through the
20 years of history so and if these are
free to download if you've never
listened to any of them before
just two idiots talking uh sometimes we
have a guest sometimes steve sanderson's
on and everybody's smarter
uh so i'm gonna go 2002 to
in roughly an hour as quickly as i can
so we started in 2002
sort of set the stage for what was life
like in 2002 well the biggest thing was
the dot-com bubble had burst
right so in terms of just state of being
we'd had a few years of complete
insanity
in computing
uh where every idea got funded
we were way past just like the bad ones
like pets.com
everything got funded they had everybody
had too much money and that ended in in
late 2001 early 2002 and it dried up too
much arguably it shrunk right down so
kind of wasn't a cool time to be a
programmer like it was ta it was a tough
period
but the sort of core aspects of
development never change the insanity or
on the web sort of slowed down and i
always keep an eye on the hardware so
every so often i'm going to throw you up
to like current state of hardware at the
time
uh
pcs looked like they had looked for the
past previous 20 years
by 2002 they
the advancement by 2002 is they were
black not beige
but
back then the mac was already gorgeous
right the g4
was a beautiful machine i mean it ran a
motorola chip which didn't make anybody
happy
but they were beautiful and this was the
top selling phone in 2002. the nokia i
think it's a 1200
its claim to fame was the screen was
sort of color-ish
all
like 1800 pixels in the display
and
you know phones will evolve
now previous to 2002 of course all that
dot com boom stuff we had been doing web
development but in fairly archaic ways
like we had front page
for those who may remember
a good way to do damage to your web
server
um the product i liked was was
dreamweaver in terms of
a real way to build where you were still
doing some visual coding
and page creation but it actually wrote
html that didn't make you sad
uh microsoft stack was uh the first this
was actually the first version of visual
studio was nine they called 97 and they
had packed all their different
development tools into it visual basic
foxpro
j plus plus which was a version of java
that they had licensed from sun a couple
of years before
intradev which was their first attempt
to do web development
and it was extraordinarily bad
uh and then you have source safe and a
few other bits and pieces there the the
implication was this was a unified
development tool it wasn't
each of these different products had
their own ids in them they're just in
one box
with a lot of
three and a half inch floppies
like 60 of them
uh and on the microsoft side of course
we were using active server pages which
was our ability to use activex
components and have it render into an
isapi filter so the first version of
that was uh
was version one was 96 they got the
version 297 and the last version version
three was actually in 2000 so by 2002
this is technically already an obsolete
technology
but the w3c has now ratified xhtml
because
xml html is not ugly enough and tim
berners-lee is convinced that xml is a
good idea we'll get over it
but at the time it seemed like a good
idea and i i would be remiss to talk a
little bit about.net because in the pdc
in 2000
uh is when microsoft first said the
words.net it's important to remember
that this is the time when the
department of the united states
department of justice is currently
prosecuting
microsoft as a pernicious monopoly which
they will succeed in convicting them of
and that actually happened before this
pdc and that's when bill gates stepped
down as ceo and steve baumer takes over
ceo and so
one of the things that
steve talked about at this event when we
first heard about.net was that it was
going to be built on open standards
that he published the specifications for
c-sharp and the runtime as ecma
specifications
so they would be available for anybody
to use and somebody did an extremely
young miguel dia casa in 2001 when he
was 29
which is the same year that steve baumer
called linux a cancer
uh started his mono project
now
i'm not going to say this ruined
miguel's life
but having spent a long time talking to
miguel about this he mean he really
liked the language
and he would and he thought making an
implication where links was a good idea
but it upset linux people because you're
working with microsoft technology and
they're the they're the enemy
and then when you try to talk to
microsoft people like aren't you that
linux guy
so life it was hard to be miguel like
miguel was definitely in a trap
but uh you know he was making things he
believed in he had a great team around
him it would take him a couple of years
to get a good version out but he would
get there
and we would see
um the release candidate in 2001 uh i
don't really bring up this slide and by
the way this slide looks really nice
but in 2001 this is the graphic for the
conference and it was 320 by 200.
so the reason this looks nice is i paid
a designer to make me a 1080p version of
it
i'm that kind of guy
uh this is when internet explorer 6 gets
released
separate
from uh from xp so ie6 shipped on its
own i.e 6 also shipped before css1 was
ratified which is why
it was a disaster
but it had its own version of css that
nothing else ran
and so when we finally do get xp it does
come with ie6 which is why it sticks
around so long because people kept xp
for forever
but by 2002 we do get the first version
of net called visualstudio.net it
actually has 22 languages
included in the box that was the claim
to fame this was the counter to java
remember microsoft had making their own
version of java then some microsystem
says you're not allowed to do that
anymore
so that's that leads to c sharp and
where
java's mantra at the time was one
language any platform microsoft's mantra
was any language one platform
the platform was windows or better or
worse the trick is naming 22 languages
because it's hard
there was eiffel.net
once
made it for onerev but a bunch of
languages still supported ibm still
maintains a version of fortran.net
fujitsu still maintains a version of
cobalt.net
and then we we have a bunch of others
okay and of course
activeserverpages.asp.net was the new
version it had nothing to do with asp
much like visual basic.net had nothing
to do with visual basic and that made
people sad
uh and i have had chances to talk to
folks who led those teams back then who
got very nasty hate mail and admittedly
for me who was a developer at the time i
cut over to c sharp because it confused
me less i knew because if you were
working in vb.net you kept writing vb
things that did not work
at least when you're writing c sharp
there was no mistaking you are not
writing vp
so you know c-sharp made me happier
uh also a fallout of the dot-com
bubble bursting was you know the
collapse of netscape in the sort of
reassembly so it's in 2002
the firefox appears the mozilla project
right the mozilla being the monster that
ate mosaic
which was the original browser that
became netscape
and so this that's how old this product
is and it will be successful for quite a
while you know it's never gone away but
it will grow and grow its peak will be
about 2009 it'll be about a third of all
browsers
it'll be sort of its high water mark
but then chrome shows up and ruins
everything
uh so that's an interesting interval
those early development periods we're
really just talking about
trying to find our way in the web in the
fallout of that collapse
client server development largely
doesn't change
right
in
2002 we're just getting at the
beginnings of net and and enter and java
development with java beans like they're
not that good
but if you fast forward to five years to
those new technologies have really taken
hold so 2002 was sort of a bracing part
but by 2007
uh some things have changed
dell made
last
you know pcs that are red and silver
that was the xps
uh with the core duo in it
and that is the
um
the first generation mac with the intel
core doing it as well mcintosh has now
given up on the power pc chipset has
moved over to intel like everybody else
and the most popular selling smart phone
in 2007
is the nokia 1200
we'll talk about the iphone a little
later because it was not that popular
when it first came along this is also
when we get safari
right 2003 is when the first version of
safari comes up for the mac and that
will create its own set of problems but
it's there you know we're starting to
see a duel between
the rendering engines these different
browsers what do and what do we want to
have we've got i.e
doing its thing we've got safari doing
something we've got firefox doing his
thing
ruby on rails by 2005. i mean today dhh
david heinemann hanson is kind of a bad
word
but at this time he was
he was a i want to say so much of a
prophet but he was somebody he built
base camp in fact still builds base camp
which is one of these email based tools
that was so fundamental to a lot of
folks and
he was responsible for grabbing an older
language a language from the 90s called
ruby that was a dynamic language and
coupling it with a scaffolding system
called rails
just to approach web development a
little differently you know to if i can
point this at a database spit me out the
logical forms based on the relationships
in the database right scaffolding so it
was very quick way to write software and
then you have this dynamic language in
ruby that was really kind of fun to code
in
now and as long as you stop there you
were fine
now if your product was actually
successful you were going to be punished
for that
because scaling it was tricky there was
a lot of
stunts you could do in there but it did
put the scare on to microsoft because
microsoft had been pretty stodgy in the
way they were doing web development they
were abundantly aware of how much ruby
on rails was accelerating web
development was the the hot thing to go
uh it's hard to imagine but
the first incarnation of amazon web
services goes all the way back to 2002.
amazon's a warehousing company right and
destroyer of worlds and so their
primary goal was
was being able to get as many stores
onto their infrastructure as possible
and so they were coming up with a way to
build sets of virtual machines on demand
self-service virtual machines
it happened to make the cloud it was an
accident
but those first they we don't hear much
about this early these early days
because they literally turn this entire
product off twice
before you get to 2006.
where it sort of sticks to the version
that that um that we now kind of know
about
it um it took a while to evolve
if they relaunched in 2006 was s3
and ec2 and their their version of sql
store
uh microsoft is trying to get hit with
web development so they start a
conference called mix
in 2006. it was very fun he's in las
vegas by the way
also remade by a designer for me because
see how nice it looks i have the only
one
uh
and so this is where they're trying to
have web conversations a little broader
this is also where ie7 comes out so
there's been a five year gap they
released ie6 in in 2001 now it's 2006
and they put out ie7 anybody wondering
where that team went for five years
they were building avalon which we now
know as wpf
because after they put out ie6 bill
gates was pretty much convinced okay
we've solved the browser
now let's rewrite the internet and his
original intent for what would become
xaml was a better language for the
internet it didn't end up going that way
but that was the original tent and they
spent five years on it and i would also
point out that that's also the period
where he stepped down as ceo and he's
now chief architect and he clearly has
too much time on his hands
um
microsoft started codeplex i have not
built a nice high scaled version of this
graphic you will notice
uh
at the time sorry open source source
control was mostly source forge
or your own private
repositories the the idea of social
coding what github became is still a few
years away
but
the motivations for coplex were
interesting because part of it was
microsoft was on a very much enterprise
development pattern of 18 to 24 months
to deliver a new version of studio
and so it was a long time to wait and
when you had in the open source
communities where you had things like
ruby on rails that were literally
iterating weekly
maybe monthly
the powers that we were concerned about
how can we deliver more code more often
and can we interact
with our customers about it
as we go and so koplex was a place to
put source code that they were
developing internally and get feedback
that people could download and utilize
and then get give feedback to and that
would iterate that way and a lot of
stuff landed on koplex one of the i
think the first hit that arrived at
coplex was the ajax libraries
so tooling to allow you to do
interactive pages
and that would eventually grow into spas
but that's before this time
but many more important products will
end up on coplex and there are a way for
microsoft to iterate on products
independent of that slower studio cycle
uh and i'd be remiss if i didn't mention
some of the big hits of like 2007 like
vista
and
this thing
yeah um this is june of 2007. it was a
2g phone in a 3g world so we was soundly
made fun of
uh the interesting thing of course is
that
they found the form factor like
this is it for phones after that like
before the iphone phones were kind of
cool
right you could get attachments and
antennas and keyboards and sliding
things and so forth and after the iphone
it's all slabs of black glass
so in a lot of ways the phone ended
there
now of course they will iterate quickly
and make a better and better phone and
we all know how quickly it caught on
jobs says at the time
if you're going to program for the
iphone you'll program in safari
he was wrong
very quickly hackers figured out how to
break the jailbreak the phone and so in
a panic to not lose control of the phone
he releases his in the internal
development tools
for the iphone
which is why they were terrible
right coco xcode all of those two was
they were internal tools they were not
meant to be used outside of apple and so
they were not very robust
and took a while arguably never to make
them better
yeah
it's only degrees of suckage
um
and
along came
silverlight
now wpf had been released in 2006 as a
fallout of vista
so they made a ver they made a sort of
pseudo version of net right in 2005 they
had net 2 now they were created a.net 3
which is just like net 2 just with extra
addressing
and that included all the things that
fell out of vista which was wpf wcf
uh
workflow card space it was a host of
different tools not that anybody inside
of microsoft used them they sort of
pushed them onto the.net team it was a
net team's problem
silverlight
was originally its code name was wpfe
or windows presentation foundation
everywhere
now there are simple rules at microsoft
one of the rules is if you have a cool
code name like avalon
you get a crappy product name like
windows presentation foundation
and so the folks that were leading this
project said let's start with a crappy
code name wpfe so we get a good product
name silverlight
where does the name silverlight come
from well what is silverlight
there is a thing that is silverlight do
you remember the old
uh
rotating square bulbs for your camera
when you take pictures
and then flash
they were all one shot they had little
magnesium coils in them so
it would flash once and then it would
turn 90 degrees and that would give you
another five you get four to a cube
the debris after you fire that flash
is called silver light
because silverlight is what comes after
flash
so
the original version had no dot net in
it whatsoever it was it was an engine
for reed hastings for netflix to be able
to run the iis media player to do
variable speed
video transmission so you could vary
between from 240p up to 1080p
automatically they had all these encoded
streams and this was the player side of
that so this is what built netflix
subsequent versions would they'd
incorporate dot into dot net into it
which meant building a runtime for net
that ran on the mac
in 2008
and they used coplex to iterate on it
they would put out three versions of
silverlight in two years which is not
normal for microsoft so it was a fast
moving thing
uh another response to to rails and to
web development was the.net mvc
and uh
one of the major participants in that
that particular product is uh out that
is here
scott guthrie was was interested in
getting this product made he led the web
team at the time
it was elion i believe that actually
wrote the original versions of it and
then he showed the prototypes to various
open source types that he liked that he
thought could be a part of microsoft and
so he used them to to bring them in the
push towards open softs was getting so
serious inside of microsoft and also
outside of microsoft there was a group
of folks that were trying to convince
microsoft to use more open source code
and i first encountered them as the dot
net rocks guy
trying to interview some microsoft
people at the mvp summit about about a
product called entity framework
this is before it was released and so i
went to one of the meetings the sdr's
for the pre-version of entity framework
and there were a group of folks in there
who were a little animated
they were banging on tables animated now
these guys were all into n hibernate
so hibernate was a java orm and they'd
made a net version called end hibernate
and it was a great product if you really
liked xml because it made lots xml
uh it was you know it has problems
there's an open source library so these
folks were very much into listen don't
make another orm help us with and
hibernate
right that was the the push they were
making and they were vociferous
uh so i called them the end hibernate
mafia on.net rocks
and within a week they called themselves
alt.net
uh
they weren't wrong
especially if in the context of today
right of using open source libraries as
part of your development practice in the
microsoft community
in 2008 that was a pretty avant-garde
idea and here you know 14 years later
it's not
one would argue their methods
they were
a little intense
but
these were the early days of open source
at microsoft and there was a move
towards it things mvc also lived on
codeplex and was iterated via its
communication with the community
and
mvc was used by scott guthrie to hire in
these open source folks and it was folks
like phil hack and rob connery and scott
hanselman
and so they did a book together
this is a composite picture from the
book cover it's a giant lie they were
never in the same room together
and scott guthrie's head is actually
bigger than all of those guys
rob connery's head's not that big
i know i've
you know so i measure my friendships
based on the number of continents i've
been drunk with you on there's a couple
of twos and threes in this room right
um
hanselman doesn't drink so won't he
won't count
got
connery's a three packs of four
got three's a five
but uh yeah all friends and uh that was
the mvc book and really the push towards
open source that started cashing on
inside of microsoft so microsoft was
building mvc by writing the code
internally taking a cut of it pushing it
to codeplex making it available for
folks to play with they call them
previews
and you would take it out for a spin and
you'd give them feedback
and they you know ran into various
features that they would need to
incorporate and by 2009 they get v1 and
we'll talk a bit more about that as we
go further along
and we get let's jump up to 2012. and i
would argue this is the darkest time on
the microsoft side but it's a great time
for web development
devices
uh the macbook air is now the sexiest
laptop uh in the world at the time by
far it will also julienne cabbage right
it's the edges on it are pretty sharp be
careful
and and dell makes the air equivalent i
guess
a little thicker a little bulkier
this is the era of the p4 laptop so it's
like you can put it on your lap but you
may not be able to have children again
afterwards right
uh and
we have the iphone 5
and the uh and the samsung galaxy the
smartphone movement is well underway
android is definitely a thing uh
we got in by 2008 we got the first
version of chrome that's really the
decline of firefox for better or worse
uh almost exactly the same time is when
google does their app engine
and that will become
the um
google cloud platform right this is the
beginnings of that everybody's
responding to aws
we'll talk about microsoft's response in
a moment
uh this is also the era of
destroying internet ie6
ie6 won't go away
uh it's now this browser is
like seven eight years old
right the ie seven and eight are still
out and ie6 is still more popular
right and and we talk about the ie6 of
browsers this is because it was popular
but not compliant with standards
right pretty much the way safari is
today
and the problem that meant is you could
build a web page
for everybody else and then you had to
do something that would work for ie6
and it was actually dhh once again put
out a letter
in
july of 2008 where he said listen
i'm not writing any more ie6 compatible
code in basecamp i'm done if you're
still using ie6 upgrade or die
and a whole bunch of folks jumped on
board um
there was a norwegian online newspaper
that was like next and they literally
you'd go to their site on with ie6 it
would pop up a thing that said this site
does not render in ie6 go get a real
browser here's links
all right and even and then handsome and
jumped on board too it's like you really
need to stop using i6 but it's because
people held onto xp this this
persistence this is vista's fault
right this won't actually get fixed
until windows 7 ships
because we we all skipped vista for
various reasons you know that was the
holdout
so we get rid of ie6
and we focus more on
uh the evolution of
of silverlight so we get up to
uh version 4 by 2010
i got to talk about this book
in december of 2008 doug crockford wrote
javascript the good parts because
apparently there were some
um and that and everybody i've ever
talked to who worked seriously on
modern javascript who got into
the v8 engine and chakra and node
this book hit them hard doug crockford's
an interesting character and and what he
was you know his point was there are
this this was not a good language it was
scripting languages tightly down to the
bound to the dom
and
if we uncoupled it it would be better
and these were the parts that would make
sense right it was a very thin book
because javascript the bad parts was
really thick
um but it it was an a for me i think it
was a very pivotal moment a lot of
important people that were going to work
on javascript from this point forward
got to work i think that's in 2008 and
in a few years javascript will be
transformed
this is also the era of ray ozzy as the
architect at microsoft and he's the one
who announced
the
windows azure right the windows cloud
uh it won't matter much at that time the
funny thing is that
what he was actually describing at the
time the web role in the app role was
very much
serverless computing
at a time when nobody wanted it
right we were buying
vms from amazon and we knew how to do
that and if you wanted a coding engine
that you didn't have to own you just
could deploy code to it there was google
app engine for that and they were so
they were sort of google app engine sort
of not like it was a tough time azure
didn't make a lot of sense this early on
this is also when sun microsystems
finally runs out of money and oracle
buys them
and uh
for better or worse and of course that
it's going to impact java the most and i
haven't talked a whole lot about java
through this because for the most part
java's just been doing its thing but his
son started to peter out so we got when
we got to five
uh there was now like a five year span
or if java 6 comes out in 2006 there
won't be java 7 until 2011
and that is the period where sun starts
to sputter and it's oracle that ends up
buying them
for better or worse you know i think for
the most part oracle seem to ignore java
for a long time they seem to be paying a
bit more attention now iteration rates
are going up
java's getting more robust
uh windows 7 comes along and finally
puts vista to bed and everybody's
happier hooray
uh and we get um
the first version of windows azure in
which supports java
net
php
and their version of sql azure
and then the big ipad a big iphone comes
out
in some ways i feel like
um
phone development was in a safe place
before the tablet came out because we
were making m dots back then right it
was normal for you to build a desktop
browser edition of a website and then
you build a mobile edition of a website
you wouldn't try and combine them the
tablet ruined that because three is too
many
right you're not going to make a tdot
now we started dealing with things like
media queries and so forth um
this is also
uh with this this this guy's announced
in march of 2020
and then studio 2020 ships in april
and this was a big deal right the
version 4 of dotnet
cleaned up all the stuff from vista as
well it's where we first got the ability
to compile the 64-bit it's when we wpf
modernizes because wpf is actually part
of the gui of studio the first product
of microsoft to actually use wpf is
visual studio
we get f-sharp
and we get jquery in the
box now why the heck was jquery in the
box well go back to mvc and coplex so
microsoft's maturing mvc and version 2
will ship in studio 2010
and they realize they need a dom tree
navigator as you do if you're going to
get
serious about modern web development and
so they start writing their own and they
push it out through codeplex and much
like the n hibernite guys with any
framework
the mvc guys on koplex go don't do it
we're all using jquery just use jquery
and microsoft listens
and so for the first time includes an
open source library in their retail
product you can still
request tech support from microsoft for
jquery
because it's still included in the box
and microsoft for their own rights will
contribute to jquery and then we'll help
set up the jquery foundation which today
we know as the javascript foundation
but
i look at it as a milestone for
microsoft that they shipped an open
source product as part of their product
it's like we're taking a dependency on
jquery
all right you if you're going to use mvc
you should be using jquery and we'd
argue we should be still using jquery
because apparently we all are
um
google releases the first version of
angularjs
in 2000 it was originally an internal
product in 2008. it's fun to spelunk the
old websites about this because
folks were using internal google sites
and they really liked the way they
interacted and so they started sniffing
through the code they said there's some
internal library they're using here
that's cool like i wonder how we get it
uh
internally at google there the team that
had built this thing
was selling trying to sell it to other
teams within google and it was one of
the vps inside of google that said hey
if it's really that good why is nobody
using it out in the wild why are you
making us use it and so they productized
it
and made
originally just called angular then they
decided to redo everything for version
two so hence the angularjs right which
is the old version the one x versions
and angular is now started with two plus
and what are they at now 14
because they iterate numbers
uh non-stop so
and i see this as the maturation of the
single page application of the mindset
of
i don't care what's on the back end i
just want to make api calls
and i'll do my rendering on the front
end
and this will spawn view and react and
durandal and many other
libraries in in this vein but
it in a lot of ways starts with angular
for better or worse
this is also when we we have to solve
the media query or responsive web design
uh 2009 is when we get css3 media
queries and so now
the ability to render to different sizes
and to change specifications on the fly
so that it works on all the different
platforms uh doesn't mean you used it
right
as with most technologies if it's
actually good enough
it you can make a mess right it's like
css it's your foot
and the real battle of the browsers i
think is in
starts in big time in 2011.
when ie 9 comes along and the chakra
engine is starting to do optimizations
in a big way they start using the gpu
they start doing pre-com and the chrome
team's doing the same thing and every
time they ship a version that hits new
performance numbers they send the other
team a cake
right with uh with their with their logo
on it and congratulations like they were
kind of having fun with it and so was
the mozilla team like they they were
doing important things in that
implementation as well but
node
which had been around for a couple of
years at this point when they moved over
to the v8 engine
was this real context of javascript
doesn't have to live in a browser
now i can have
a server-side engine that is by default
off right which is not how web servers
existed before that like
iis and apache both had the same
tendency they were the swiss army knives
with every blade out it's like what do
you need i have everything and it's all
on
right you know the name apache is not
necessarily the
the the
native americans from america it's
literally a patchy server
you install the bootloader on it and
then all it does is pull patches in
so node was the opposite of that it was
i do nothing until you tell me to do
something
and you're going to have to build each
blade you need and you're going to build
it in javascript
and you're gonna like it
uh and it's i feel very fundamentally
philosophical different way to think
about it but it also reflects the era
you know by 2010 2011
we're pretty tired of being hacked
and this default behavior of turning
things on it's wrong you need to only
minimize your surface area you know
instead of iis actually starting to turn
stuff off no you ran another piece of
software that figured out what was on
and helped you turn it off
so you know now in my mind node was
incredibly important at that time
because it just said you know you don't
have to do it this way you can actually
approach it from the only turn on what
you need perspective
but microsoft's not finished kicking
itself in the head
it's 2011
and they're announcing
windows 8.
this is the first build
i was there with carl
it was a developer's conference and they
didn't talk about.net
at all
they did talk about winjs
because they were they figured you know
the point had been that
they needed a lingua franca
right that was going to work on all the
platforms there was now a diversity of
platforms between ipad and iphone
android devices as well as windows
devices there was
billions of them and so you needed
something was going to work across all
of them and the only thing that were
across everything is javascript now the
only reason that broke
was because of steve jobs jobs didn't
want
flash to run on the ipad because it
killed the battery
so he wrote a letter
thoughts on flash
and what he was re what he said which
was also true
was
we can't have plug-ins anymore
and if you remember back in 2010 2011
right in that in that exploit era every
one of your family members had an
address bar that wasn't an address bar
at some point they clicked on something
that it replaced their flip and address
bar right that was the plug-in error
and so what jobs were saying was true
plug-ins bad
make plugins go away
and that was bad for flash but also was
bad for silverlight
and so
that was the death knell of that and so
by the time we get to
build and microsoft trying to respond to
the ipad by making a tablet version of
windows
they're convinced that javascript is the
future
they were wrong
thank goodness
uh and my and carl and i walked out of
build in 2011 in anaheim going hey
maybe.net doesn't rock
and we make a show called.net rocks what
are we gonna do so we made the tablet
show you remember the dates we started
in 2011 like a month after build we had
another show running and we
we do it for three years and i do tablet
topics and cross-platform development
there
and then after three years like it turns
out.net rocks we'd rolled it back into
dot
uh microsoft's also working on the
rosalind project at this time now
the simplest way of a look at rosalind
was it was a comp a c-sharp compiler
written in c-sharp now this is a normal
thing for mature languages to do
right once you kind of happy with your
language you should write a compiler for
your language in your language i know
it's recursive but it's something that
happens but you realize this is 2011
like the language now 10 years old is a
huge install base and they've not gotten
around to doing this so why they do it
now
and the main reason they did it at this
point was visual studio
because visual studio had
its own intellisense compiler for c
sharp as you were writing c sharp it was
evaluating it and putting squiggly lines
on telling you how you're doing it wrong
and then it also had the main compiler
that you had to compile to separately
and everything was bad if those two
things weren't perfectly in sync and the
feature set was getting large enough
that was getting expensive
and so they wanted a compiler as a
service one compiler that could do all
of the things that is what got roslyn
over the line they act but they
originally started developing rosalind
through codeplex
so you could take rosalind out for a
spin as it was being developed and some
interesting products are sort of
spawning off of rosalind but because it
was open source and complex
there were no go live licenses there was
no there were it was all supposed to be
for experimentation only and there was
an outcry around that and they
eventually invented a license where if
you downloaded it and deployed it
yourself into a piece of software then
you could have a license to run it much
as you want but you couldn't package it
in existing pieces of software and so
folks were building installers that
would then force you to go to a browser
to download roslyn so they could do the
installation for just to be compliant
with the license
they'll fix that it'll take a little
while uh in that dark time of
of.net a much older miguel diakaza this
is 2011 as well
like it's kind of crazy when you think
about this right thoughts on flash winjs
you know no focus on.net whatsoever c
sharp is doomed miguel de casa shows up
the um
novel has been bought by attachmate and
novell had been had owned mono for a
long time an attachmate looks at mono
and says huh this doesn't make any money
you can stop developing on it now
and miguel doesn't think that's a good
idea at all so he calls his name his
friend nat friedman and says we got to
do something and they make a new company
and then they talk attachment into
giving them all the rights to all of the
mono related things including mono touch
and mono touch was an implementation of
mono that compiled onto the iphone
he'd had it he'd had it working for a
couple of years at this point and in
2011 he got it working in android as
well
and on the show i said hey
microsoft doesn't seem to care much
about c sharp these days but miguel sure
seems to because i can run c sharp in
all kinds of weird places we had the
rosalind project where we were standing
up scriptable c sharpen in its own
little run times and having a good time
with that and here was xamarin now
running it on the iphone and the android
like c sharp was alive and well just not
at microsoft
[Music]
uh web development takes a great step
forward in indifference towards design
with bootstrap in august of 2011. next
typescript so
at the end of 2010
anders halsberg stepped down from
leading the c sharp team
and put mads targets in charge who's a
great shepherd of c sharp but it scared
a lot of people at the time it was all
part of this narrative of c sharp is
dead you know anders has moved on and so
forth he was working on types he'd
gotten fascinated with the javascript
problem and he wanted to make it better
and that would become thai script
although it would take a couple of years
but it was part of that scary era was
how do we provide good typing systems
for a non-typed language right for you
know
typing to javascript and wildly
successful there's another very
important aspect of javascript of
typescript that i think most people
weren't aware of
microsoft was convinced they could never
be good in the open source community
right that they were always the bad guy
and me and anders pulled to prove them
wrong when typescript shipped in in in
2012 the the betas the openstack
community loved it because it was a
problem that actually needed to be
solved and serious open source groups
started at doing the plugins for
typescript the palantir group actually
wrote a typescript plugin for eclipse
and there's so suddenly there's all this
evidence that when you actually build
the right thing in the open source
community the open source community will
embrace you even if you're microsoft
and it shifted minds inside of microsoft
it was an impactful moment for them to
actually change that enough that they
made a new version of their logo
after 25 years and they've this is when
the three colored blocks shows up
microsoft's trying to figure out how to
do open source right
in 2012 they started a group called ms
open tech
on the outside for all of us
it was about making sure they were
good.net libraries for
major open source libraries so redis
memcached all those kinds of tools this
is where they would make sure that they
were they they maintain good libraries
so those products all work well but also
internally they have microsoft employees
working on open source projects but they
created a wholly owned subsidiary called
ms opentech to make that work
because
lawyers
i don't think it was necessary they'll
eventually roll it up in 2015 but that's
what they did at that time
the other thing that happens in 2012
is uh we get the version of visual
studio for 2012. this is the one that
supports the first time they support arm
processors because they're now making
the surface machines that are armed and
we show off just how
great.net is because they can just
change the runtime and boom you compile
on arm magic most people remember studio
2012 for
all the menus are an uppercase and that
is horrible
and so we get to build 2012 when windows
8 ships
and all the focus that they put on
building code in javascript
results in
two percent of the apps in the windows
app store are built
using winjs
and 80 of them are built using c sharp
dotnet and xaml
so they may not have loved c sharp a
whole lot back then but c sharp loved
them back
didn't save win eight though
and so we get to 2017.
everybody's hardware is a bit sexier
except for the mac the mac has gone from
silver to black but the pro has 18 cores
it's like they're out of they're out of
the cool stylish ideas so let's just
make it big and fast the iphone 8 is out
now in rose gold because that's a good
idea
and the x the new version of the xps is
sort of vaguely silver and it still has
a dvd in 2017
for some reason
but back up a little because in 2014 we
have the transformative build
this is the build where
sachin nadella does his first keynote as
ceo microsoft
and he leads with windows is free for
devices with screens nine inches and
smaller
if you want to think about the change of
microsoft's thinking at that point
that was what he led with for a reason
windows is no longer the center of the
company
azure's the senator the company and so
we will give away windows when it makes
sense that's also why he renames
windows azure microsoft azure
because that's what they're building the
whole company around now this is when
rosalind which was originally
a windows only product done on codeplex
moves over to github and is a
cross-platform product
so
they you know the shifts are happening
now that they're building all of the
things this way
it's also in 2014 we finally ratify the
specifications for html5 and css which a
lot of people have been counting on for
a long time i mean it doesn't fix all of
the problems
but
the web has a language now and an
approach to the language is sustainable
we'll go into the you know rolling
equipment specifications going forward
that make it a lot more robust
and microsoft makes their next hit in
the in the open source community in this
form of visual studio code
the first intentional hit in open source
it's like what could we do to make a
really great editor
planned from the outset it's going to be
open source all the way like what would
we do and they did it and it's now i
think the most popular editor on the
planet for better or worse uh but it
also to me speaks to how the company
evolved that they recognized this is in
their best interest to build this is
cross platform or open source from the
outset not migrated to it not also and
but the whole purpose would be like that
we get windows 10 and the weird version
of microsoft edge that nobody wanted to
use
although it did use chrome plug-ins
somehow
um it'll eventually evolve into a
version of edge that's a little more
interesting for folks but wind 10 was
also supposed to be our last version of
windows
2016 xamarin gets acquired
becomes part of microsoft these guys go
inside
um
nat will go on
to
be the ceo of he'll work inside on the
tfs team and then he'll go be ceo of
github when they acquire that a couple
of years later miguel
uh gets involved with
dealing with xaml and a bunch of other
cool projects both now have left the
company by 2022. so things have moved on
and now we're definitely getting into
steve sanders's space because
when barriman and russell published a
specification
uh over on the chrome team for the
progressive web app it's like how do we
involve web development to be more like
just app development
have a manifesto that we have an icon
have services that persist across
connectivity problems you know that is
the evolution and it's still an evolving
thing but we're trying to make web
development more robust
it uh if microsoft finally commits to
rewriting.net
as a cross-platform
uh open source project it was cheaper to
rewrite it than to try and fix the old
one
not the old one was broken as long as
you were running it on windows but it
was built from the ground up to be a
tool for enterprise developers to build
windows apps and it was hard to change
that so it was easier to start over as
challenging it is and then i saw my stan
friend steve sanderson
in 2017
in oslo
with web assembly and this weird version
of c sharp he'd found and he was running
she sharp on the browser and all our
heads exploded
like you're doing what
and webassembly been around for a while
when really what it was was a way to
expose the runtime of the browser
so that you know javascript lived within
that and the fact that you could simply
insert another language into that space
was interesting and he was i think one
of the first to really show what the
possibilities were
uh and it scared microsoft i think
that's a fair thing to say it kind of
put it over in the corner he's sitting
right there have to talk about a guy
when he's sitting right there uh and
they sort of put it in a corner it's
like we're just going to make this a
research project for a while we're not
really sure what to do although that
next year miguel diaco very publicly on
twitter goes i think this thing is
awesome and it should be running on mono
and we're going to make it work
and it got better and it became what we
now know as blazer
and it felt like microsoft hesitated on
that long enough to wait till somebody
else went first i think when the go
implementation was really running well
as web assembly then they relaxed a bit
but you know that they that pattern of
evolution and this approach to open
source is very interesting
a challenge for microsoft the kubernetes
story to me is another important one on
the open source story and this evolution
development containerization is a
logical extension of virtualization
right this is you know at the simplest
obviously containerization is
virtualization we're getting the
operating system out
just make my code let's can i stop
having gigabyte
virtual instances i just i'll tell you
what os i need to run you find an
instance to run it with go
but from a political perspective
it was more for us as developers
organizing code that way starting to
have a manifest for all communications
rights building fundamental perimeters
but also talking about portability
running in different places and nobody
seemed to get too upset about docker
containers we're all fine with that poor
dockers never made a penny on any of it
but we're all going to use it and that's
great still runs better on linux than
windows that's because windows is having
a tough time with this
but the orchestrators were the
interesting part because there were a
bunch
docker was making swarm there was uh
dcos mesos
and there was kubernetes and kubernetes
came from
google
right he's actually part of the google
uh of gcp it was this fellow brandon
burns
who led the project inside of google
and then microsoft poached them
brought him over to microsoft and then
gave him space to build a version of
kubernetes around in azure
and so suddenly you could if you were
working in kubernetes containers they
ran equally well on gcp as they ran on
azure and the amazon guys weren't having
any of that and so suddenly amazon had
implementation of of kubernetes services
and that
impact the market because now all the
big players
could run the orchestration engine for
you and you could run it at home
and so the other orchestration engines
kind of didn't make sense
and the side effect that was enough
people getting together suddenly an
ecosystem group around kubernetes
kubernetes is far from perfect but now
we're getting tooling in the forms of
stuff like helm and nav and and to help
you work in that space it's like we
wanted a monopoly one orchestration
engine
but it's not monopolized by any given
vendor it's an open source project
contributed to by multiple of these big
companies and supported by all of them
and that to me seems like a really
interesting evolution of the way things
are going to work going forward i'm not
saying it's all going to be good
open source is being changed by the tech
giants and this is one of the examples
it seems to be beneficial but we have to
pay attention to the fact that open
source is being transformed by the
presence of these titans
uh 2017 is when coplex goes into archive
only it's now flatly down
you know we're all in github now for
better or worse microsoft took a long
time to get deeply involved in github
the original uh github logo i mean this
was about social coding that was the
concept and then they got the octocat
and all those other cool graphics but
by 2018 it was bought by microsoft
largely
to the relief
of folks you know it was kind of leaked
on a friday that they were going to
announce they were buying it on a monday
and there was a few folks like oh my god
i'm going to git lab i'm getting out of
here and they're like gitlab even that
thing that runs on azure okay
uh
but it was always tough for this company
to make money and here now it kind of
didn't have to it been held as a wholly
owned subsidiary nat went to run it for
a time which most folks that were at
github at the time knew him and had
confidence in him now it's thomas demke
who's taking it over from there
but
it's the repository for source code for
most of the development community for
better or worse
and dot net core is now grown up they
have made uh well we'll have we're now
on an annual cadence so net five came
out in 2020.net six in 2021 dotnet seven
will be at the end of 2022.
so we're and now they've changed the
life cycle so net5 is already going out
of support
where a long-term supported version
of.net is three years
they're basically insisting that we keep
our code being buildable
another side effect of
the github ownership is this beginning
of using machine learning inside of
programming and understanding code
so i mean there's lots of fun things to
talk about in this era now
this technically historical but it's
absolutely current around artificial
intelligence
i mean the problem is we've made movies
right the first movie really was 2001 a
space odyssey
1968 it's an old movie but it's the
first time like artificial intelligence
is an ancient technology right first the
term is coined in the 50s but it was a
science term it wasn't for regular
people but kubrick brought it into
regular people
in 2001 a space odyssey with hal who
then tried to kill everybody gee i
wonder why we're freaked out by ai
um
but they've taken all that code feeding
it through these advanced parsers in the
open ai space and now we're seeing
things like github co-pilot
and uh and the um the game maker
where i'm writing out descriptive
language into gpt three and it's
spitting out code all right this is open
ai's codex
so the you know this is an old
um
william gibson line the future is here
is just not evenly distributed
if you push on the sort of edges of what
we're doing in coding you're seeing
these new technologies and they're not
replacing us you're still writing the
intent of what you're supposed to do
it's still just a tool extending us
but
this is today this is current history
right
i mean we've done things like alphago
where we solved playing go but have you
seen what the technology that alphago
has done lately you know the second
iteration with alpha zero was a more
generalized engine where you literally
showed it a set of rules and it started
playing itself well those same guys are
now working on an alpha fold
alpha fold is them using that mod that
modeling system to figure out protein
folding
for the most part ai technologies that
we've seen in the past few years have
done things that we could do
just not as quickly or as inexpensively
or hard to pay attention to you know
using vision recognition to find cancers
in a radiological screen that's
something a person can do but the
computer is really good at it and faster
at it this is something we can't do
we've been trying to solve protein
folding problems for a really long time
and we basically have to do it through
brute experimentation
but they have built a model for
calculating protein folding behaviors
that's now scoring in 80 90
accuracy rates and that is
a fundamental change and it's a
different kind of programming this is
very biological programming
but it's part of the technology that
we're currently working in
uh we're out of time
and certainly not out of topic
there's more coming and actually the
talk i'll do on
friday on the next decade of software
development
picks up from here and goes out
right and i'm going to make some guesses
but i'm a good guesser
so we see some things that are coming
from there and i hope you'll come and
see us there thank you for your time
you